Ten minutes to start!
The showdown between Porco Rosso
and Donald Curtis is about to begin!
There's no rules. The first one
to run is a coward forever!
Shut up! We came here for a dogfight.
We're not here for a lecture!
Shut up! Open your mouth and we shoot you!
A ten-ton bomb would be better.
This fight decides the fate
of our beloved Miss Fio Piccolo...
who needs no introduction!
Know what I mean?
A big hand for Fio! Applaud!
Get on with it!
Quiet! There are formalities to observe!
Both sides will place their wagers!
-Please sit down.
-Thank you.
Put it down!
No complaints? All right, shake hands
and come out flying!
Forget it. I'll keep my hands clean.
That's not very friendly.
We'll go straight to the church!
Don't worry. My mother says
you can get used to anything.
-May we have a picture?
-We took a bath!
Smile, everyone!
Smile!
Ready...